in this video I want to explore the
question of what impact does the
environment have on human migration and
we have a couple specific examples here
and before we dig into those I want to
make a few broader points about the
environment as a historical factor and
the first of those is simply that the
environment does have impacts on what
people are able to do on how and where
they're able to move we might be looking
at is the climate suitable for
practicing agriculture food production
is such an important part of a human
movement in human survival in new
environments we might look at
transportation in the Pacific Ocean for
example getting from island to island
requires that you have technology that
allows you to travel over the ocean from
long distances the second point to
consider more broadly is that human
beings when they move to new areas tend
to have impacts on the environment so if
they're bringing new plants or new
animals to a place where they haven't
previously existed that's going to have
some impacts on the new place and
finally this isn't to say that the
environment is wholly explanatory of why
history played out the way it did but we
also don't want to dismiss the
environment as a potential explanatory
factor so with those bigger points in
mind let's start by looking at a
specific example in Africa known as the
Bantu migration or more often the Bantu
expansion into sub-saharan Africa and
when I say sub-saharan Africa that's
just the region of Africa that is south
of the Sahara Desert and I'll shade that
in here so that you can see where I'm
talking about and next what I have is an
overlay in yellow that shows the areas
of Africa where a Bantu language is the
the predominant language spoken so the
question that raises is why does so much
of sub-saharan Africa speak a Bantu
language there there aren't any written
records of Bantu speakers and and how
they moved and what they were thinking
when they did move but there is evidence
in terms of how the languages relate to
one another and there's also
archaeological evidence so one of the
helpful things about studying the bed to
expansion is that from about 500 400 BCE
on they were using iron tools they had
iron making technology and those tools
along with Potter
that's distinctive too to bantu-speaking
cultures can help archaeologists trace
how Bantu speakers spread throughout
Africa over time so linguists who have
studied how these languages relate to
one another and archaeologists who have
looked at evidence of how Bantu speakers
migrated and moved throughout Africa
are fairly confident that they
originated somewhere here in West Africa
and from there spread to the south as
well as to the east over to what's known
as the Great Lakes region of Africa and
then from there farther south again so
that tells us how people moved through
Africa what pattern did they follow the
next question we want to try and figure
out the answer to is why did they
migrate to the places that they did well
one thing that we know about
bantu-speaking peoples is that they
tended to have fairly consistent and
common agricultural practices and among
the crops that they were growing were
millet and sorghum once they got to the
Great Lakes region and started moving
south you also see them adopting cattle
herding pictures of the cattle that they
would have probably had here and what
these crops in these cattle have in
common all of them tend to thrive in
what's known as a tropical savanna or a
semi tropical savanna climate and
sub-saharan Africa with the exception of
this rainforest region here and this
high desert down in the South is largely
tropical or semi tropical savanna and
when we put the overlay back up of where
Bantu speakers are the majority we can
see that sort of corresponds with those
climate variations you see them populate
really all of the areas that are
favorable to to their agricultural
practices and that should make sense if
we think about migration as a
risk/reward calculation you need to make
sure that any place that you're
migrating to is going to be able to
provide you with food so to bring that
back to our big theme how does
environment impact migration we really
see in the Bantu expansion the role of
climate affecting what kind of
agriculture as possible and that
determines what areas look attractive
for migration so the next region we want
to look at the next migration we want to
study is that of people moving
throughout the Pacific island
you can see the path this migration
probably took here and when we talk
about expansion in the Pacific we're
looking at something somewhat similar to
the Bantu expansion in Africa and that
again we don't have any written records
from the people who moved here so again
we're relying on linguistic or language
based evidence as well as archaeological
evidence and this evidence helps us sort
of divide up the Pacific into three
distinct regions so we have what's
called Melanesia in blue and Micronesia
in red and Polynesia in purple and again
these are all people who were originally
speaking some form of Austronesian
language very similar culturally but
they can look at how there have been
small changes in cultural artifacts
changes in languages and even in the
genetics of the people and the animals
in different regions of the Pacific to
kind of get a sense of of where they
were at what time and that gives us this
this probable route of migration that we
saw so thinking again about environment
impacting this migration into the
Pacific Ocean
there are a couple of important factors
the first and obvious one is that
getting across large stretches of ocean
is going to pose a difficulty it's an
obstacle and the way that people
overcame this obstacle in the Pacific
was they came up with better sailing
technology and I can pull up here a
picture of a recreation of a catamaran
this technology was really important for
travelling long distances in the ocean
because to get out in the open ocean you
need a sturdy a durable ship that's
going to hold up to wind and waves so
even though this is a modern recreation
it gives us a good sense of what the
technology was like and you can see how
that that would be a more durable craft
than say canoe by itself so this allows
people to travel between islands the
other issue
environmentally speaking that poses an
obstacle to expansion in the Pacific is
that a lot of these islands are really
small you're probably noticing that some
of them are quite difficult to see on
the satellite image and they don't have
a lot of arable or farmable land on them
and so they could cancel
or large populations and this is
probably one reason why there is
continued expansion in the Pacific over
a long period of time is because the
islands themselves can't support very
large populations if the population
grows to a certain point some people
have to leave so to deal with this fact
that the islands didn't provide a lot of
natural food people would bring their
own food supplies with them so they
bring things like sweet potatoes and
yams and taro root and they would bring
animals as well so chickens and you have
a picture here this is what's called a
Southeast Asian red jungle fowl and it's
the precursor to to domestic chickens so
it can give you a sense of what some of
these chickens probably looked like they
brought pigs they also had a small breed
of dog the dog breed is extinct now but
we have some pictures that were drawn by
some of the early European explorers of
the Pacific so people would bring these
items with them they'd bring these
animals with them onto these new islands
they would grow the crops they would
raise the animals and use them as a food
source and to go back to our original
list of a big takeaways this gets into
this idea of environmental impact of
bringing these new plants and animals so
what happens is that people bring these
plants they bring these animals that are
not native to these islands on to these
islands and use them they farm them they
raise them for food and in most cases
people are able to sort of strike a
balance of maintaining a food supply
with these crops and animals that
they've brought and not destroying the
island environment because obviously
that would have consequences for their
ability to continue to live there
hopefully it's clear at this point that
environment definitely played a role in
these migrations in these expansions
certainly this isn't only about
environmental factors but in both cases
it would be very difficult to explain
what happened if you didn't include
these environmental factors